Chris is with us Chris is in Dallas
Texas hi Chris how are you hello Dave
thank you for taking my call
sure what's up so I want to talk to you
I want to see when you're some advice um
and what would it be the best thing for
me to do at this point so my car got
repossessed
last week and I've been you know I've
been behind on a couple of payments so
by the time I made up the payments they
still came and got it yeah so how much
was your moment I'm sorry how much was
your car payment this is a luxury SUV
Cadillac you know I got it so much Oh on
said car you all about 27,000 so your
interest rate was ridiculous
no it's just an expensive car my
interest rate was I think he was 5.9
which you know I guess it's kind of bad
for a car yeah and what's your household
income right now I make about a hundred
and seventy five a year okay making a
hundred and seventy five a year why did
you not keep your car payment paid you
know how much other that do you have
well I have another work truck that I
used for my company to run my business
or chat page six hours a month on that
one what kind of truck is that it's just
a pickup it's a work truck it goes 600
bucks a month
uh-huh we had a cup truck yes yes okay
yes what do you do for a living I mean
the vending business okay
and what does that pickup worth the
pickup is is really upside down I don't
want to know how much is worth I do know
what you owe on it on the pickup truck
you all about 20,000
almost on the other car okay I just got
it about a year ago all right and what
other debts have you got sir well I have
you know I have my house I have my house
how much is your house payment
husbandman is sticking out at all hours
a month okay it's actually it's actually
1700 yeah aren't you and what else and I
have my wife's living home as well which
fell on still all about there too in
Belgium okay yeah your work trials nicer
than your wife's car okay no my work
truck you know it's really beat-up now I
think you know more on it than your
wife's car I got you go ahead yeah how
much other day so total bad you know I
didn't mom you got any other debt other
than these three cars in your house no
that sees a couple credit cards I think
I have about $6,000 worth of credit
cards and there's still no reason making
$175,000 you're talking about $175,000
profit no that's before taxes and before
expenses so you know overall I'll
probably make about after taxes and
everything in my 120 you know no taxes
after your business expenses right do
you because there's a you understand the
difference in gross profit or gross
revenues and net profits correct huh
what is your net profits of your
business before taxes are paid uh yeah
about 175 okay so that's just before
taxes or so so how old are you 28 no sir
I'm 39 okay cuz you're out of freaking
control dude I mean you know that right
yes I know that I know that and this
just happened within the last couple
years you know bicycles okay here's what
I'll do here's one out there the car
that was $1100 was insanity it's gone
what was that car worth this Wars about
maybe 37,000 because I kept up with it I
you know it and you only oh honey you
only owe 27 on it
correct have you talked to them about
what have you talked to them about what
it takes to get it back yes so yes in
fact I just talked on my few Howard
what's the deal
they won thirty five hundred dollars
that's all that's all that's mm-hmm okay
so if you put thirty five hundred
dollars in you turn around sell the
truck you make ten thousand of your in
you get your thirty five hundred back
plus sixty five hundred right yeah yeah
okay so put the thirty five hundred out
there get the truck back in her and sell
it immediately nothing what I thought
about yeah that's what you need to do
but because this truck is stupid
anything that anything that sounds like
an $1,100 car payment is straight-up
stupid mm-hmm okay man I'm it's just
nuts and what's even crazier is making
all this money you didn't even bother to
pay the bill yes I know that's just
crazy land okay so that tells me you're
out of control you don't have any kind
of a money management system going
inside your house I'm picking on you but
for your own good cuz dude you you're
just so freakin smart you make you have
the ability to make so much money let me
tell you what I was doing when I was
your age okay or not when I was really
just ten years younger than you I
thought I could out earn my stupidity I
thought I could make enough to be stupid
yeah and that's kind of what you've been
doing in it yes cuz you know I make
money yes you're good at making money
you're just not good at managing it once
you get it am I wrong that's correct
no you're exactly right people don't
make a hundred and seventy-five thousand
you're not stupid you're just doing some
stupid stuff on the spending side of
this equation so you got to turn this
around you got so much potential man
there's so much you're gonna be right so
get that car back and get it sold drive
your work truck mama drive her truck now
you got thirty three thousand dollars in
debt if I had it this up right not
counting your house doesn't do that
right that's correct but you're gonna
get nine thousand how this transaction
when you get that you throw it at Mama's
car I want Mama's car paid off in two
months I want Mama's car paid off by
Christmas
correct the money you make on the repo
that you buy back and flip plus any
other money you squeeze out of your 175
income Mama's cars debt-free by
Christmas does that sound cool don't
that work truck off in just the next few
months and then you're gonna start
piling up some cash and whatever you
whatever you buy is a car in the future
you pay cash for it or you don't buy it
and hold on I'm gonna send you a copy of
a booklet if you promise Kelly you'll
read the book I'll give it to you it's
called the Total Money Makeover and you
need one this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]